foreign
North Carolina hi Mary welcome to the
Ramsay show
me
so much for taking my call sure what's
up
so um my husband ever mentioned to me
that he had a second 401k account from
his previous employers and I came across
all this while we were doing the
budgeting
um and mind you we've been doing
for like a very long time the question
came about because we have a sixty
thousand dollar credit card debt and my
question was well can we pay some of it
from the 401K and I think that no you're
totally against that right yes I am but
the the bummer is that he never did tell
me he had another second 401k
which amounts to almost 250 000 dollars
so he's still putting you know money
towards that 401k plus the current
employers 401K no it's not
you can't add to a 401k at a company you
no longer work for
you can only add to account 401K in a
company you actually still are employed
by
okay
yeah you're putting 15 of your income
towards retirement right now
yes that's what he's putting in
in the current employer
in the current employer he's not willing
to take the money out because he says
it's not feasible
feasible no I wouldn't take it take it
out of the 401K or you mean he's not
willing to stop adding to it
correct he's now willing to stop adding
to the 401K oh what's not feasible is
the fact you people still have 65 000 in
credit card debt that's straight up
stupid
right I agree with you 100 well so his
statement his statement is asinine
I'm going to keep putting money in this
while we overspend over here and never
reduce our credit card debt that's dumb
so we were making the we were making the
account and trying to figure out how
much oh how much more you're going to be
losing so he's putting in
and his company matches up you guys are
not you guys are not in agreement on
what your goals are
okay you need to sit down and decide
what we're going to do with our money
and if you're going to follow the Ramsay
plan of getting out of debt so that you
can become wealthy faster
then you would stop your 401k
contributions temporarily while you
attack this but y'all have been playing
footsie with this he sort of kind of
goes over here to the side does whatever
the flip he wants to do you go over here
and try to clean up his mess on the
other side
y'all aren't working together
you're working against each other
you're not going to get this money stuff
straightened out as long as you do that
yeah I I sit down and I tell him look
this is what's going on no that's not
how it works you don't get to tell him
anything we have to decide together that
we want to follow a path to become
wealthy
and he's not even listening no matter
what you tell him you're just selling
like Charlie Brown's teacher in the
background wait wait wait wait
that's what it sounds like to him
because he's not even on board he's just
tolerating this thing that you're doing
so the two of you need to sit down and
say together what are we what are we
going to do honey I need your help with
this I need you to come alongside me so
that we can get out of debt so we can
become very wealthy because what we've
been doing for the past several years
has gotten us to where we are and where
we are sucks and I'm kind of tired of
this sucking stuff and I wish you would
get tired of it too and we could work
together on this
but right now you feel like you're
trying to drag him and you're getting
increasingly disgusted with him and he
probably tired of hearing you nag yeah
yeah am I missing something
no sir yeah so I think this is a
marriage communication thing the Bible
says where there is no vision the people
perish you all don't have a vision for
where you want to go together
like if Sharon and I decide we're going
to go on a trip and I don't know make up
a we're going to go to Florida okay then
we decide together that we're going to
Florida otherwise I gotta duct tape her
and throw her in the back seat and take
her to Florida and that's that's a
problem problematic it's called
kidnapping so you know it just doesn't
work so we have to go we have to talk
about do we both want to go to Florida
yeah then we can talk about what's the
fastest way to get to Florida are we
going to buy airline tickets or are we
going to get our little butt in the car
and drive down there I you know you can
get all kinds of methodologies once you
both agree on the goal together but if
if I want to go to Florida she don't
want to go to Florida I end up in
Florida by myself
yeah and Mary I would just mention this
credit card debt I would mention what it
feels like as Dave touched on but I
would I would introduce some numbers to
the conversation this is what we're
paying every month in credit card debt
and this is the interest they're
charging us and and appeal to his sense
of money yeah I'm scared share it share
your fears I'm scared this is not
working and when I get scared I get mad
and then I start nagging you and I'm
tired of being a nag I don't want to do
this and I'm tired of you not listening
to me too you know we got to get on the
same stinking page here man this matters
yeah and then you all decide together
what you're going to do and that way
you're not pulling in different
directions and set a vision for where
you want to go that that that's what's
missing here
um
is you're trying to do
all these Ramsey tactical things that we
teach and both of you are not doing it
yeah I was going to ask you is we listen
to this story
he's looking at it we we presume he's
going well I don't want to give up that
retirement money to try to pay off debt
and I think it needs to be a complete
switch of it's not just about that my
friend it's about what happens if you
pay off that debt you get on the other
side of that and all those credit card
payments now turn into the baby step
plan it's like he's so focused on
stopping he doesn't want to stop
investing in his 401k that he's missing
everything else well I mean she feels
like you're selling a credit card debt
making it you know paying 18 on it
you can't think that's a good 20-year
plan exactly no one logically can go oh
that's a wonderful plan let's just keep
doing it it's more like I hate that that
it's over there but I just don't hate it
enough to do anything about it yet right
right you know you got to hate it you
got to get sick and tired of being sick
and tired and busted in the mouth and
that's when you that's when things start
moving man nothing moves unless it's
shoved and so you get sick and tired of
being used to have that I've had it
moment and then you're willing to do
whatever it takes to get there that's
when you start moving stuff around in
your life particularly money stuff